there has never been a time when every
piece of news has been equally
horrifying there's never been a time
when every article every click
everything that you see is as
nightmarish as every other thing that
you see it is a wave it's like if you've
ever been to a beach and you get knocked
down by a wave and you keep trying to
get up and you keep getting knocked down
and then you're just laying there in the
surf that's what this is I mean this is
an amazing period of time I mean and the
media makes it worse I mean it's bad
it's undeniably bad in fact it's so bad
the only joy you have is calling people
and telling them that they don't know
how bad it really is that's the only
bright part of your day is calling
someone in the morning and letting them
know that they don't even know how [ __ ]
they are you get those calls every day
we all compete to deliver the bad news
we're all like Paul Revere except we're
not riding through the night on a horse
we're sitting on our couch watching
Netflix and then every morning we pick
up our phone and call somebody you got
to see listen this quarantines not
ending there's gonna be chips in our arm
it's you know we're not going back to
work anytime soon kids aren't going to
school in the fall college is getting
pushed back you're never gonna eat out
in a restaurant again everybody you know
is dead you were dying
you only have one lung working right now
you're looking I feel kind of good shut
up you don't know how [ __ ] you are
that's the only bit of joy we have you
get giddy you get giddy you get giddy
and I like to call people because most
people I know now have resigned
themselves to the fate that this is
going to be a long hard
as Donald Rumsfeld would say but every
now and then you'll catch somebody with
a little hope with a little hope with a
little like spark of hope and you get
excited because you know you're about to
crush it because you know you're about
to extinguish their tiny amount of hope
they go yeah man to go you know probably
start opening up in the summer and you
go oh you ignorant piece of [ __ ] you
know nothing have you not read anything
30% unemployment massive bank failures a
rise in homelessness the pandemic will
never end they go yeah yeah I guess
what's gonna change between now and July
tell me I don't know that I got yeah
you hear them sink sink a little bit
lower and then you go all right talk
soon it's the only choice you have now
is bringing people down and then
sometimes it's fun to lift them up a
little because you got to lift them back
up to crush him again so I call people
every other day and do good good cop bad
cop so yesterday I called everybody told
him quarantine was going to log is to
push in school back in September comedy
clubs will never reopen they all had to
get new jobs and that you know we're
gonna see millions of deaths today I
called him with good news you know I
cherry picked some you know some some
you know positive news you know which
there's very little of by the way it's
just surreal and then I lifted them up a
little bit and I like to confuse them
they don't know they don't know where
I'm coming from they don't know where
I'm going with it
because sometimes I like to give because
sometimes I'll be I'll be wheeled down
and then up then they'll be real down
but then I want to go motivational and I
go but but here's what you got to
realize but my motivational is different
than other because this was tuning
errors tell people is going listen we're
gonna be okay I'll tell you why and they
go why cuz they're in New York I mean
they're shut in New York is America's
Italy right now they're they're singing
in the streets I mean it's wild you know
what I mean and as a New Yorker as the
guys that grew up in New York it's
[ __ ] wild to watch you know from LA
um you know not there I'm not there and
you know like my friend was like she's
like everyone there such annihilate such
a narcissist she's like I'm glad I'm in
you I'd rather experience this with New
Yorkers and I'm like well good for you
she goes that's where we differ I said
indeed absolutely I'm glad we've
identified that divergence of opinion
but I was saying today I said the
American economy's gonna get back on
track because Americans don't put any
value on human life their own or others
and that is a good thing it is a good
thing that we are a deeply suicidal
country with a death wish it is a good
thing that we arm ourselves to the teeth
and sit in our little survival bunkers
waiting to be allowed out so we can go
walk our fat asses onto a cruise like
nothing ever happened it's gonna happen
again those boats will be full people
are gonna be back in Applebee's putting
quesadillas in their ass because that's
what we're about they're gonna be back
to friendly fire incidents in their home
their four-year-olds gonna find the gun
they bought for the pandemic and he's
gonna blow their brains out with it
don't worry about it thank God thank God
we have a country of people who truly
don't care what happens next because
that's the only thing that's gonna save
us Europe is [ __ ] they're gonna sit at
home and ponder we're gonna go write the
[ __ ] out as soon as we can get drunk and
crash our cars don't worry tow trucks
will be working you're gonna be working
GEICO's back in business as soon as we
can get back in our cars and hit someone
we're gonna do it as soon as we are
allowed out we're gonna cause some
problem problems we're gonna cause some
bodily harm and that's what we're about
that's the only reason I am hopeful I
don't trust the government
I don't trust the private sector the
only thing we have left is science truly
I mean the
only way out of this is a vaccine or an
antiviral drug like maybe this
chloroquine ein helps that they're that
they're giving to people alongside
erythromycin which is the you know the
drug from the z-pak you take for
bronchitis maybe that gets approved as
an official treatment it did in France
maybe that helps
maybe there's another antiviral that is
in the public policy solutions here are
not going to please anybody there are no
good solutions there are waves of this
pandemic there's waves of the virus you
let people back out the numbers will
spike the number spike the hospital
suffer you don't let people back out the
economy crumbles you know it's not
there's no way out as Thomas Sowell said
no solutions only trade-offs here and no
good trade-offs either I mean it's just
you got to decide at one point what is
the more destructive path but you're
worrying you know you know you're
waiting for science you're waiting for a
guy in a lab coat that's a hell of a lot
smarter than me or anyone I know
who's [ __ ] feverishly working on a
vaccine for this because god help you if
you think Donald Trump or Joe Biden is
gonna figure a way to put the world back
together it's not gonna happen in the
short term or the long term your best
hope is science and science takes awhile
that's why everybody's freaked the [ __ ]
out the average length of time it takes
to get a vaccine going is 15 to 18
months that's not terribly encouraging
that's what most experts are saying and
until we get that most articles that are
dribbling out now are preparing people
for a longer haul than they originally
were they're saying that life is not
going to go back to normal until we have
the ability to prevent people from being
hospitalized so that could be done with
a vaccine or that could be done with an
antiviral that somehow
prevents hospitalization so that it
becomes what people said it was a bad
flu for those 20% of people that would
have been the hospitalized it becomes
what it is for those 80% of people a bad
flu and again this is all as of Friday
uh you know April 2nd 3rd it's the 3rd
yeah Friday April 3rd April 4th
we could have an entirely new that's
what's great you could wake up on April
4th and they could go boho by the way I
remember how we told everyone to wear
masks now everyone should wear hazmat
suits
if you leave your home so please put on
the hazmat suit before you go to the
grocery store and everybody's gonna walk
around looking like astronauts why the
[ __ ] do I have to wear a mask if I'm
alone walking around an area that I'm
too poor to live in which is what I do
every day I walk around Beverly Hills
alone I don't talk to anyone nobody
talks to me it's LA nobody spoke to each
other
pre-pandemic we leave each other alone
why I'm not six feet from anyone why do
I have to wear a mask is the virus just
sitting around in the air stop if it was
truly airborne everyone would have it
stop it I get it if you're gonna go to a
grocery store if you're gonna have an
interaction with somebody but I'm
certainly not wearing a [ __ ] mask to
walk down the street if I'm not near
anybody I understand in New York
everybody's next to you I get it
you know I'm just asking the media to
give us a minute give us a minute not
every story like the media is now like
the stories are like transgender
surgeries are being put off because of
that it's like okay can you give us a
minute here abortions are not being
provided sigh that is sad but can you
give us a minute with it do you have to
unearth every negative thing that's
happening now don't we have enough
every human interest story and I get
that these are stories that need to be
told
do we have to tell them all at once do
we have to tell them all at once at
least we wait until the towers fell in
9/11 before we started printing up the
stories of the dead Debra was a mother
of six her lung collapse like oh my god
it's bad I know if the people are still
playing frisbee shoot him if they're not
taking it seriously shoot um I guess I
don't know
but to stop writing these stories you're
trying to guilt people that to stay in
but they're not gonna do it the NYPD the
LAPD they shoot people for a lot less
than this I'm not saying if you're
jogging or walking but if you're in a
park with a lot of people I don't know
shoot him you don't have to kill them
rubber bullets gas them teargas what are
we finding I don't know I mean you know
there's no good options is what I'm
saying here you know I don't want it to
radical government but I'm just saying
if I saw a bunch of [ __ ] tick-tock
kids in LA getting tear gassed I might
smile a little bit I mean you know